it reads dear Dominic thank you for your
letter notifying me of your decision to
resign from your position in his
Majesty's government as Deputy Prime
Minister and Lord Chancellor and
Secretary of State for justice it is
with great sadness that I have accepted
your resignation when I became prime
minister in October last year I pledged
that the government I lead would have
integrity professionalism and
accountability at every level the
ministerial code requires ministers to
uphold the highest standards when formal
complaints about your conduct in
different ministerial posts were
submitted last year I appointed at your
request an independent investigator to
conduct a full investigation into the
specific facts surrounding these
complaints Adam Tolley Casey has now
submitted his report and I have
carefully considered its findings as
well as Consulting the independent
advisor on Minister's interests as you
say you had rightly undertaken to resign
if the report made any finding of
bullying whatsoever you have kept your
word but it is clear that there have
been shortcomings in the historic
process that have negatively affected
everyone involved we should learn
uh we should but it is clear there have
been shortcomings in the historic
process that have negatively affected
everyone involved we should learn from
this how to better handle such matters
in future but your resignation should
not make us forget your record of
delivery in both this government and
previous Administrations
these achievements should make you
extremely proud most recently as
Secretary of State for justice and Lord
Chancellor you have put the rights of
victims at the heart of our criminal
justice system through our Landmark
victims and prisoners bill as well as
increasing sentences for violent
criminals
reforming the probation system and
pushing forward the biggest prison
building program this country has seen
in over a century as foreign secretary
you were a major driving force of the
2021 integrated review conceiving and
delivering the indo-pacific Tilt I know
the personal drive you also displayed to
create the UK's new independent
sanctions regime and in our response to
the undermining of Human Rights and
democracy in Hong Kong it goes on during
the covert crisis you stepped in when
the then prime minister was hospitalized
you provided the country and your
cabinet colleagues with reassurance and
Leadership at a moment of profound
National concern as Chancellor at the
time I was struck by the Collegiate way
in which you handled this most difficult
of challenges I will always be grateful
for your steadfast personal support
during last year's conservative party
leadership contest from the day you
introduced me at the launch to the last
day of the contest the subsequent
dedication commitment and loyalty with
which you have discharged your
responsibilities as Deputy Prime
Minister has been typical of your belief
in public service I look forward to
receiving your support from the back
benches as you continue to passionately
represent your constituents of Isha and
Walton thank you for your service to
this and previous governments and I wish
you and your family every possible
success for the future yours sincerely